I must admit I didn't think much of
Graham Norton first time I laid eyes on
him look like a stiff breeze could blow
him over that was my first impression of
the man I could see why some people took
him for annoying he had a walk and a
talk that just wasn't normal around here
and boy did he drink
he drank like a man without a care or
worry in the world I hope to finish this
talk show one day I hope Michael stops
talking for justice I hope people stop
asking me to do stupid boys over the
line from Forrest Gump where he suddenly
discovers how much he likes running I
would happy to do it but you must show
the lady with a cute card because
otherwise people will think that I've
actually memorized this is Ryu MO this
is for you mom and now you wouldn't
believe me if I told you but I could run
like the wind blows from that day on if
I was going somewhere I was running
there's an awful people in the audience
who love you so I will wait in calm down
so I'm just gonna give an opportunity
for some of them to say I love you so so
we're that oh look at her a blue hand
right up there okay what's your name
Anna Anna and send up were you for
minute sorry sorry love Harrison that's
the point now wait a minute okay so
there he is he's not gonna you nearer
okay
look them in the eyes and tell him oh
wait wait for the music I love you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
contaminants have a go do you mind yeah
sure
hope you sign up what's your name
yoga what yoga from Belgium Yoko Yoko
Yoko do you live here now no I don't so
you're just here from Belgium on holiday
I came for this yes to see mr. Ford yes
[Applause]
music there he is there he is there yes
there is always music I love you thank
you
[Applause]
the kingdom to step back there you this
is this real good reaction to a fork
well done this one's a nice light one oh
I see I could do that
I do break a lot of these okay I mean I
do break a lot of them but
[Applause]
yes
it's amazing it do that do you do you do
the thing when you know that it's going
to do it but you still do it do - you do
it on top of things do it can you give
us some lines sure sure
drive it a me out let's see it with the
girls voice
[Applause]
yeah that was really good have a go
Henry going off what would Superman say
there I was standing there at the church
first time of my life I realized I
[Music]
[Music]
I wasn't the person standing next to me
[Music]
there was the person standing opposite
me
is it still raining
you did me and you were very good you
did my laugh very well do you do lots of
people are you one of those actors yeah
but I mean I think I think I think a lot
of us up here don't we I mean it's
either music or it's or it's it's it's
voices or tongues of voices I mean you
know ice and muck around with
dictaphones at school for ages and just
you know do interpretations
impersonations of people and great
characters and it's it's just sort of
having in the air it's part of what we
do I guess I mean even if it's not a
real person just to imitate or have
empathy with at a state or a human being
of any general you were doing - back at
during the clip
what's our time with the - back a thing
just natural nature that's what my
favorite ibaka moment is just that
[Applause]
gonna take you back you opted to be back
okay doctors sure look at him go
boys team selfies like a meeting
[Applause]
[Applause]
so sorry I left that in from early I
always let travel with food on the go
smack come on
oh you're so hot
[Applause]
then some of the special effects were
simpler than maybe they are now so the
the Jedi mind control when you can move
objects explain how they did well first
of all George called Star Wars the most
expensive low-budget movie ever made was
every penny had to go up on the screen
and the ingenuity was fantastic so for
instance when I was hanging upside down
in the Whomper cave they'd had fishing
wire attached to it and pulled it out of
my hand and then just reversed the film
so it's very simple but I mean the the
ingenuity is tremendous now they CGI it
and spend way too much money let me see
if we can recreate it in a very low-tech
way I'm going okay so if I give you know
if you move that like you do all right
no no you're good in orange
well maybe a better movement further
brigades my aim is off so you can if you
could try to get just in that general
vicinity so hang on wait wait wait wait
wait so we've got to look astonished
this this will make sense we've got to
look astonished when Mark is holding in
the orange and then slowly back nothing
as the orange lands okay okay okay so we
all set right
okay okay I think we've got a good run
was that good okay okay yeah let's watch
back let's watch back you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]